as the opening day of the second world
war fades
limp strains to identify the ship in
front of him
it's behaving in his opinion
like an auxiliary cruiser because it's
zig-zagging
and it's blacked out and he even
imagines to have seen gun platforms
in lamp's mind that is enough proof this
is some kind of armed enemy ship
fair game to be attacked without warning
with torpedoes ready
a little before 8 pm lamp fires the
first two u-boat torpedoes of world war
ii the hydrophone operator monitors them
by the sound of their propellers one
speeds towards the target
but there is a problem with a second it
should grow fainter
but instead is getting louder
fearing that it will circle back and
strike them
lamp orders the u-boat deeper
it is a scenario they train for even in
peacetime
the standard procedure is to dive below
the depth that a torpedo would pass
it could be tight u-30 is more than 210
feet long
and as the bow angles down the stern
goes up
they must get the whole u-boat out of
danger
they have no way to visually monitor the
threat
your only source of information is what
the hydrophone operator can hear
when the noise finally fades away the
torpedo no longer poses a threat
relieved lemp surfaces to investigate
with darkness falling he moves in for a
closer look
the first torpedo had struck the ship
but as lamp surveys the crippled vessel
he realizes that something is wrong
they checked the silhouette of the large
ship against the lloyd's register of
when he saw the scene of action he
realized that he
was mistaken it wasn't an auxiliary
cruiser it was a steamer with a lot of
civilians in the water
an intercepted radio transmission
confirms his fears
it identifies the ship as the passenger
liner
ss athenia bound for canada
lamp has made a huge mistake his orders
were clear
sink only warships troop ships and enemy
merchant vessels
hitler and the german government still
hope for
some kind of settlement agreement with
britain
and so they don't want to aggravate
the british more than necessary now on
the very first day of the war
limp has sunk a passenger vessel without
warning
comparisons are immediately made to the
sinking of rms lusitania
by a u-boat in world war one
an act that helped end american
neutrality
and brought the united states into the
war against imperial germany
the exact scenario hitler hoped to avoid
with his strict instructions
now the sinking of athena sets off a new
political firestorm
many of the 1103 passengers aboard are
canadians
americans or european refugees escaping
the war
118 civilians are dead
hitler and his propaganda minister
joseph goebbels
vehemently denied german responsibility
for the attack
the man responsible for hitler's
headache his 26 year old oberloyd
nancers
fritz julius lemp he was born as a son
of an army officer
in china before the first world war he
entered the
rice marina in 1931
and he went to the new created
submarine arm in 1936. he was assigned
command of his own submarine u-30
in 1938
[Music]
lemp recognizes the potential fallout
from his error
he makes no radio report of the sinking
and continues his patrol
you have to keep it secret and he
decides
to stick exactly to the submarine
protocol
for his future attacks
[Music]
you